from the University of Michigan thank
you so when I ran into Rooney in the
hotel when we arrived she was telling me
how she was a graduate student here and
she was here during the earthquake
sometime when the Bay Bridge sort of
collapsed on itself and I'd she was
telling me what a traumatic experience
this was for her I didn't want to tell
her I was going to talk about monitoring
the structural health of bridges I
thought she would be worried for a
couple of days so I i I'm going to I'm
going to tell you about monitoring
bridges for their structural integrity
and their health so this started out as
a project with some some folks in in in
the College of Engineering at the
University Michigan and you know this
seems like sort of a pedestrian I'll be
an important problem and so buried in
here are a bunch of interesting theory
questions that came up along the way but
you know I'm also going to tell you
about bridges okay oh so I should say
this is a joint work with Jay young Park
who is a graduate student at michigan
and Mike wakin who is at the Colorado
School of Mines okay so um yes I'm sorry
I'm sorry Renee these are pictures of
collapsed buildings to emphasize that
you know it's important to assess the
structural integrity of things like the
I the i-35 bridge in Minneapolis Jay
tells me that this was a department
store in Korea that collapsed you know
he remembers this and you know so this
yeah it's critical that we monitor these
these things and so my colleagues in the
College of Engineering and civil
engineering have developed a platform
wireless sensor platform that they stick
on bridges and buildings
and you know ships all over the world
and these really cheap risa these really
cheap sensors can acquire vibrational
data so they sit on the structure and
they just measure how much the you know
how much the building shakes then they
transmit their data to a central node so
these these little wireless devices
they're you know they're like they're
like about this big they take six double
a batteries and so changing the
batteries in these things is a major
pain in the neck you know in order to go
and instrument a bridge they have to
close a highway they have to get m dot
Michigan Department of Transportation
out to in with their cherry pickers and
so on so they would really like ways of
acquiring data or ways of transmitting
data basically ways of dealing with
their data that that conserve battery
life better yet they want to be able to
use solar panels instead of double-a
batteries and Michigan doesn't get a lot
of sunshine so especially in the winter
they discovered that the north side of
the bridge is particularly cloudy I
don't know why this was news to them I
you know I knew this so they they you
know whether on purpose or accidentally
have tremendously undersampled randomly
missing data so they would like to know
what can they say after collecting data
over a winter and they would like to be
able to accurately assess the health of
the bridges and the buildings you know
just in case you think that the bridges
that they put these things on are going
to fall down any time soon really what
they're doing is they're just keeping an
eye on the bridge they're not trying to
decide you know is it going to fall down
in the next six months just you know
does it need repairs another thing that
there that they are that they are trying
to do is to populate say finite element
models of these structures so that
they can you know analyze various
scenarios so it's not it's not so much
to determine whether or not an
earthquake in Michigan would take out
bridges okay so you know I guess I you
know I sort of like to make the point
here that their data are not necessarily
huge but their devices with which they
use to acquire and transmit and process
the data are tremendously resource
constrained and sort of the dual of big
data is you know incredibly small
computational power and you know
literally batteries six double A
batteries you can't power a lot so you
know sort of the dual of big data is
small resources so this is a beautiful
example of small resources okay so what
is the math problem you know enough
enough about engineering what is sort of
the the math set up so they have they
have n sensors that they place on a on a
bridge say and each sensor is going to
observe some displacement data so how
much does the thing move up and down and
let's say that we concatenate this data
all of these sensors so over time each
sensor is like a great big column vector
and you know what is a reasonable model
for the shaking the vibration of a
bridge well a reasonable model or the
very simplest thing that you would start
with is to model each one of these
little sensors as a little spring and
all of these all of these little Springs
are connected to one another just say in
a straight line and so you have a really
simple system of Springs and this is
modeled by a really simple system of
second order ode to east I never thought
I would say that in a talk
hi okay so here we go we've got a mass
matrix a second order you know
differential second second order
derivative and time stiffness matrix and
you know absolutely no forcing they
assured us that this the segment of data
that we were to analyze there were no
trucks cars whatever passing over the
bridge and so there's no forcing applied
to the bridge this is you know purely
purely homogeneous setup okay so um you
know I have to teach pte so I can solve
this I can solve this the system of
equations and they have a you know
beautiful solution as a sum a linear
combination of sinusoids with different
frequencies and different phase offsets
x what the civil engineers called mode
shapes you can think of these just as
the generalized eigenvectors of the
laplacian applied you know in space
purely purely spatial so these guys are
you know purely functions of space only
these guys are functions of time and the
civil engineers call these things modal
frequencies and they call these things
shapes their eigenvectors of the
laplacian so they are real they form an
orthonormal basis and they give they
give you physical information about the
structure of the bridge and so j
computed some examples and you know this
these are the fundamental vibrational
modes of the bridge it looks like the
bridge really oscillates a lot he
doesn't doesn't have any of the
magnitude on here but you know these are
the fundamental frequencies at which
this particular bridge vibrates and
these are their fundamental shapes so
this this these modes these mode shapes
give the engineers structural
information about about this bridge and
so what they want to do is they want to
from there n sensors placed on there
Bridge acquire in a very power efficient
fashion or transmitted in a power
efficient fashion their vibration data
and from that say it's some central
location not necessary not on a really
cheap wireless device they want to
extract these modal frequencies and and
these mode shapes so they they call this
modal analysis anyway that that was what
our goal was to do so we said alright
that sounds great let's let's take this
fundamental solution and let's just you
know consider these sign way these sine
waves with different frequencies and
different phases let's just look at them
as complex Exponential's with frequency
Omega sub N and so here we've got a
superposition of sine waves in time that
are multiplying these mode shapes in
space and we are going to sample this
this solution at em different points in
time okay so we've got n sensors and
different physical locations on the
bridge and M different positions in time
right so we we have a matrix alright
okay good now we're all in the in the
realm of big data big ish data and
matrices okay so here here is the enough
enough with these pte Zanna so here's
our matrix of data you know I've told
you what each entry looks like and you
know here's the here's the general
solution so we'd like to know from this
data can we extract the mode shapes of
the bridge can we do so in a relatively
efficient fashion sort of the flip side
of that question is if the sensors cut
out and fail to record data over various
you know at certain points in time
how accurately can we figure out these
modal frequencies as a function of how
close together they are or where they're
their general extent and then also how
accurately can we figure out these these
mode shapes okay so I have to tell you
that we spent six months trying to
figure out what in the world the civil
engineers did that they called modal
analysis because it seemed rather
straightforward just to take an SVD of
this data matrix and the reason is that
if you unwind this this superposition
you've got unitary mode shapes over here
you've got a diagonal matrix that is an
Amplatz that are these are on the
diagonal are the amplitudes of your
solution and over here you've got
sampled sinusoidal dat em different
points of time and so you know this
looks like an SVD ok so the first
question we asked was how can we make
worse that I say what sort of sampling
patterns will give us a nearly
orthogonal matrix over here so that we
really and truly can just do an SVD and
tell the engineers look your mode shapes
are are the right are the right singular
vectors of your data matrix is that does
that make sense so so far all we're
doing is you know the mathematicians
approach to modal analysis and you know
what can we tell them about about you
know different trade-offs and sampling
patterns okay so this is like step zero
okay right so the key idea is a you know
we want the right singular vectors of
this data matrix and how accurately the
right singular vectors of the data
matrix is how accurate they are on
his accuracy depends on when we sample
in time how I'm not going to say
anything about where to put the sensors
in space just assume they're just they
tell us where to put them ok how many
samples we collect how many samples in
time and also how long we sample for so
it's not only how many samples in time
but also how long we Sam how long we
observe for so the number of samples a
total sample duration and then two
quantities which seemed quite natural
for harmonic analysts is the minimum
separation between modal frequencies so
these modal frequencies are do not lie
on some beautiful discreet grid you know
we're talking about a bridge and so
these are these are you know frequencies
that you know let's say could be any any
sort of real number so we'd like to be
able to say you know if you sample for
such and such a length of time and you
collect so many samples in time you can
resolve modal frequencies that are close
by to within this minimum separation
okay so that's really that's really how
they wanted to use this sort of
information and also we also the
accuracy of the singular vectors also
depends on the maximum separation
between modal frequencies what is the
lowest frequency versus what is the
highest frequency ok so the I'm not
going to give you almost any almost any
proofs I will just give you sort of
sketches of proofs and sort of highlight
the main the main the main idea so the
very first thing that we said was ok how
are you sampling right now I said right
now we are sampling uniformly
deterministically you know with the
following sampling rate we said ok let
us
let us tell you how well you can resolve
your modal frequencies and how accurate
you can get your mode shapes just just
right off the bat with this with this
incredibly simple brain-dead scheme so
we've got uniformly spaced samples in
time they're sampling interval is
something like 1 over the maximum
spacing of the frequencies the maximum
spacing of these things and we sample
for either you know login over epsilon
do you know times this ratio or you know
at least n samples then we can get the
mode shapes so the error between the
mode shapes returned by the SVD and the
you know honest-to-god ground truth
analytic mode shapes in other words the
the the singular the right singular
vectors from the sort of truncated
discrete data versus the honest-to-god
singular vectors from from a you know
supposed analytic solution the l2
distance between any two of these pairs
is bounded by you know roughly a
constant times epsilon and then times
some sort of gap here that looks like
spectral gap right so these are the
magnitudes of the here it's these
amplitudes here that we attach to these
to these individual analytic solutions
okay so if these guys are really close
together in other words you know if
these think of these as the singular
values if these guys are really close
together then you're going to have
you're going to have some trouble but if
they're fairly well separated then then
you're good okay so this is this is this
is how accurately these guys can do with
their current sampling scheme okay
even this was news to them okay if you
can do something you know uniformly
deterministically why not do it randomly
after all they're their solar detectors
are our only sampling let's say randomly
because they they drop out right now and
then so let's say that you sample
uniformly at random now I'm not making
any sort of discretized time this is
this is purely a mathematical result
we're going to sample uniformly at
random over some interval 0 to T and we
sample hour duration let's say is login
/ the minimum frequency spacing and we
collect roughly n log n over epsilon
squared samples randomly within this
time period than with exponentially
small failure probability the mode
shapes that are returned by the SVD are
also pretty close to the true you know
to the analytic solution mode shapes
okay and again we pay some sort of price
for the spectral gap of the of the
analytic solution okay what did I want
to I'm missing a slide where is my slide
okay all right I'm not sure if the
summary is here yet but we'll see what
happens okay so neither one of those two
settings that i described is is very
practical in terms of saving saving in
terms of truly saving power so what
really costs on these these little
wireless sensors is transmitting
informations basically turning on a
radio and transmitting data is is is
very expensive actually collecting the
data and storing it in memory is not is
not so expensive so one thing that they
asked us to do is okay we'd like to
transmit less less data so one thing
that one model that we came up with that
seemed fairly reasonable and seemed like
something that was sort of consistent
with with what they could implement was
the following model so it is possible
for them to sample uniformly
deterministically on a on a you know on
a fairly fine grid but it cost them too
much to transmit that data you have a
question
they're the mode shapes change they saw
what do I know about civil engineering
so yes they do change not I don't think
on the time scale over which they
collect this sort of data so um I
believe that they are they probably are
going to do this maybe every couple of
years uh you know recalculate mode
shapes maybe maybe they're going to do
this two times a year maybe winter and
and summer you know bridges contract in
the winter and expand in the summer so
you know maybe they want maybe they want
to do this at I mean you know buried in
your question is how much memory do they
have can they store all this data for
you know six months and then come and
you know download it and I suspect not I
think not
I mean really and truly these things
drop data fairly frequently and and and
so and so it's it's not accurate to say
they're collecting data continuously
because they're not how how often do
they do they you know dump the memory to
some central location I don't know I
don't know if it's once a day you know
whatever I do know that the power is a
tremendous issue the radio is very
expensive so we came up with something
you know we came up with some solution
so right it's not that hard for them to
have a clock that that that you know
that runs that has fairly high frequency
and it's not that hard for them to you
know collect a sample to be it's not
that hard for them to be able to collect
a sample on this uniform deterministic
grid it is too hard for them to collect
data randomly in time right randomizing
a clock on these little sensors is
actually kind of a nuisance so what they
can do is every clock cycle x a random
plus minus one and they can add these
things up random pseudo-random whatever
that is actually fairly easy to do I'm
messing what the clock is hard to do so
as long as you are you know okay doing
some sort of say ran random linear
combination on a regular grid then
you're okay so we said all right that
that's a good model so I'm not saying
you know sample you know uniformly at
random in time I'm saying you know take
a dot product with a random plus minus 1
vector of the samples that you know it's
okay to collect okay and accumulate
those and sum them up and transmit them
all right so it's easier to transmit one
number here that is a linear crandall
in-ear combination of the samples it's
easier to do that
to transmit all the samples I'm not
saying that it's hard to take each
sample ok does that distinction make
sense ok good ok so mathematically what
are we saying we're saying you have your
form deterministic sampling with with
which you have hit a that you have hit
with a saya johnson-luna Strauss matrix
ok and you have then transmitted that
sketched data ok so let us suppose that
those the samples these M time samples
are uniformly spaced this is your
sampling interval and you have taken
this many of these uniformly spaced
samples if you and then end you you know
mathematically you've built this matrix
X if you then hit that on the left with
johnson-luna Strauss transform and how
many rows do you have in that let's say
you have the rank of x divided by
epsilon epsilon squared and why there's
a prime there so that many rows notice
the number of then you have a much
shorter matrix why it still has as many
columns as X did originally but it has
fewer rows so you each sensor has less
data to transmit but you have not
reduced the number of sensors ok you
know I'm also you know assuming that
each sensor has the same fee inside it
that all of the clocks in in each of the
sensors they're all synchronized etc ok
so if you then look at the SVD of why
remember we're interested in the right
singular vectors of X if you look at the
right singular vectors of Y and ask how
close are they to the original right
singular vectors of X well with high
probability they're pretty close how
are they you're going to pay to error
term penalties the first one is the
first error term penalty we've already
seen just in terms of how how far off
are the singular vectors of x from the
analytic mode shapes okay so that's
that's this error term we've seen that
before and then you're also going to pay
a penalty for doing the sketching and
that penalty is this error term and
you'll see I'm also yet again paying an
error term for the spectral gap in the
singular values of X not in the singular
values of the original analytic signal
okay so this is a this is a so i think
it was Michael on the first day who said
you know there are lots of lots of real
you know scientific engineering whatever
applications where you care about you
know not just the the you know rank 1
Rank 2 approximation to your data but
you care about you know the rank rank k
for k large approximation and so this is
an application where the rank k
approximation to x is not actually what
you want these guys really want these
mode vectors they want these mode shapes
they want to know how far is is is the
true mode shape from from what you've
returned so they're not they're not
interested in using their their data
matrix X to solve a linear algebra
problem they really want to know
physical properties about the bridge and
their physical properties are these
these k different mode shapes yes
yeah so so rotations wouldn't okay so
yeah yeah okay so buried in here is
we're this between minus one and one
business accounts for flipping the sign
whether you have this this you know plus
V or minus V so that's basically what
one way to get around us another thing
is to use the spectral gap you know if
the singular values are exactly the same
you know the singular vectors are you
know they're lying in a subspace you
know up to some rotation you know that
the gap is zero you know we can't
promise anything but that's okay they're
there in these applications there are
there are gaps and when there aren't
gaps we can't promise anything which you
know is is you know it's exactly what
you would expect from from linear
algebra yeah we're not interested in a
subspace we are actually interested in
the vectors to the extent to the extent
that they're different okay ah yes here
we go okay so every time i drive to the
airport i see this bridge because it is
on the way to the airport so this was
the bridge where they actually put in a
bunch of sensors and it's an Ipsy so we
asked them for data we want to know you
know how good is this so they had 18
sensors on the bridge they had they
assured us that yes the time snapshot
that we're giving you this stuff has
these free is free vibration we were
pretty sure there were no trucks or cars
driving over the bridge at this point in
time and jay used his his favorite
johnson-luna strauss transform not
necessarily mine
his to you know sort of simulate if we
had collected data in this fashion what
would we have gotten and so here are his
three dominant modes these are the
fundamental modes that the bridge moves
in and he tried a couple of different
methods the really embarrassing part of
this work is that we kept asking the
engineers well you know what are the
mode shapes no really what are they and
they said there is no gold standard
there's just the catalog of algorithms
pick some and we said okay that's awful
and I said you know how should we
evaluate well you know the the the the
the the dot product or the difference
should be more than point 9 soon I
didn't mean it we got to be like ninety
percent you know ninety percent accurate
yeah ninety percent is good this is
awful okay so anyway we we went down
from three thousand uniformed samples in
time to 50 measurements at each node and
you know we had a bunch of different
methods for for computing this must be
the error not yeah this will be the
error not you know not not not the
actual dot product so you know we
actually did fairly well I wanted so fdd
is the is the one of the gold standards
in their in their book I also wanted to
do sort of the stupid sanity check that
reconstructing each column using you
know some some generic compressed
sensing algorithm reconstructing each
column and then using the so-called gold
standard algorithm was not nearly as
accurate as just looking at the singular
vectors so you know signal
reconstruction is not not always the
best thing to do
okay so uh we also so I'm also
interested in Fourier sampling
algorithms so we also asked Jay you know
let's go estimate these these modal
frequencies because this is kind of
interesting so let's look at the left
singular vectors of X or the left
singular vectors of Y and let's just
take the FFT of these things and you
know how accurately are we getting these
frequencies and you know we do okay i
think was with j sort of answer it
requires some eyeballing to you know
look at the peaks in these in the
spectra and say yes that's the big peak
that's the big one that's the big one
etc so this is a real ad hoc algorithm
know if not great but it's kind of
interesting that it works really well
okay so what's yes I'm sorry how can you
what
you you you think bridges are perfectly
exactly beautifully symmetric ah uu you
should drive to michigan i assure you
there's nothing symmetric ok so you know
I you know it's great to tell stories
about about bridges and things falling
down but you know there's some there's
some there's some Theory hiding in here
so so I guess the the big the big theory
that that's hiding in here is what do I
want to do yes is sketching a tall thin
data matrix on the left so that your
sketching across your sketching down
each column and collecting a shorter
matrix but not a thinner matrix and when
the singular the right singular vectors
of your sketched matrix are close to the
right singular vectors of the original
matrix what's kind of cute about using a
johnson-luna strauss matrix is that this
can be done column by column in each
sensor and it's easy to update these
kinds of sketches if you see if you see
changes kind of cute um yeah so here's
the here's the result webbing we sort of
summarized it in talking about the and
talking about the mode shapes of the
bridge ok so all right so more formally
what is the result that we get well it's
not a surprise to anybody that we get a
relative error approximation to the
singular values that sort of been this
is you know just one example of where
this is where this has been shown and
then we also get the right singular
vectors again you know up to this
spectral gap so as long as the singular
values are not equal and also
they're fairly far apart then we get an
l2 distance between this each singular
vector and the true singular vector
that's bound advice you know something
that's roughly epsilon times some
function of the spectral gap 1 over the
spectral gap ok so how does this work
well this works this is just sort of a
standard using matrix concentration
results as well as looking very very
carefully for the exact right matrix
perturbation results somebody somewhere
prove to this and to you know or you
just have to look hard enough so you
know we have our sketch of the form y
which is fee times X so this is the SVD
of X notice that if you form y transpose
Y that's like X transpose V transpose V
X sitting in here in the middle is fee
transpose feet remember fee transpose V
is a johnson-luna strauss matrix so it's
almost the identity it's the identity
plus some perturbations ah good thing we
have at our disposal matrix perturbation
results okay so here if we if we write
out what Y transpose Y is in terms of a
perturbed version of the identity from
fee transpose fee here is the original
this is you know truly what what what we
desire to define the eigenvectors of and
then here's this perturbation and we're
interested in how far off the eigen
values of this matrix are from this
matrix given this very special form of a
perturbation yes so
if you go look in this in this relative
error matrix perturbation result by
mathias and vasilich 1998 then this is
exactly the sort of analysis that we
want ok so there's I guess in the last
couple of years there has been quite a
bit of interest in sort of compressed
pca or compressed SVD so these are just
two examples of this work I know
Constantine is going to give a talk and
I on Thursday on this sort of problem so
these guys both Fowler and clean and
Hughes we're interested in the left
singular vectors rather than the right
so their aspect ratio is slightly
different and they're actually
interested in sketching in a in a
different dimension and they actually
use different random projections for
different columns sort of a peculiar set
up and then you know of course we've
heard a ton in the last day and a half
on substrates and prank subspace
approximation low-rank approximation etc
and you know all of these all of this
work focuses on finding approximate
subspaces rather than individual vectors
primarily because subspaces are really
useful for forming projectors from an
orthogonal projectors for solving least
squares for solving regression type
problems for for solving linear systems
some of these require multiple passes
over the data or you know sampling
according to to certain kinds of
probabilities etc yeah so we heard we
heard lots and lots of talks about this
so these are all these are all
intimately related but this is an
application where the subspace will will
not suffice so they really need these
vectors okay so let me let me conclude
by saying you know we started out
working on this problem i started out
explaining this to you as as a you know
a cute application but embedded in it
are a bunch of kind of interesting
theory problems so there's questions
about Fourier sampling so how long and
for and what sort of sampling rate do
you need in order to basically resolve
close by frequencies in a in a Fourier
sampling type problem compressive SVD
for actually for the actual vectors
themselves and what's kind of fun is
that you know I i can really worried
about how big is epsilon squared 1 over
epsilon squared because you know there's
this is an actual hardware platform but
that a graduate student can can can
program not not me but they can actually
implement this and they can test it out
and it's really kind of interesting to
write papers with the with the engineers
because you know they don't care so much
about Constance and epsilon squared they
would like to know how much longer their
batteries will last so it's very
interesting to talk trade-offs with with
them okay so future work for the modal
analysis stuff you know our our little
analytic solution is kind of a joke you
know this masses and springs connected
with absolutely no damping no forcing
terms whatsoever so you know a more
realistic model would be a good thing
our ad hoc algorithm for estimating the
modal frequencies is intriguing and you
know we have no theory analysis for that
whatsoever
you know and and finally there's a good
reason why those civil engineers have
more complicated algorithms than just
take an SVD because there's all kinds of
there's all kinds of noise and and stuff
that's that's in their data that we
haven't taken account we haven't taken
account of in sophisticated estimation
strategies and then finally I promised
in my abstract something kind of
intriguing and a couple people have have
asked me about it so a few people
observed and I even said a little bit
that these mode shapes are there's there
nothing other than the generalized
eigenvectors of laplacian and in this
really simple mass system they are
nothing other than the eigenvectors of
laplacian for a really simple graph in
other words the graph that's simply
align with like n vertices on a line so
you could ask right so basically this
vibration business is is nothing other
than the solving the wave equation on a
graph and you could ask you know there's
all this beautiful spectral graph theory
that's useful for solving the Poisson
equation monograph you could also ask
about more sophisticated graph analogs
of more sophisticated types of pdes and
where your operators are not just a
little playin and so i have been working
with with people on the forward problem
for pdes on graphs but also the inverse
problem where you try and infer
structural graph properties by probing
the edges of the graph and so I like to
think of this bridge problem as like
inferring the structural properties of a
really simple graph and the graph
analogs of Pease of some sort of a nice
nicer mathematical generalization
thereof ok so thank you
so we haven't analyzed that at all
that's that that's part of the more
sophisticated estimation strategies so
actually say that the civil engineers
when they when they actually do this
analysis they'll like break up their
data into chunks and sort of average the
answers they get roughly speaking
average the answers they get over chunks
of time to try an average out in a ways
so that is one sort of gross approach
that that they use currently yes
fernando
so it's so I don't believe that that's
true I believe that these sensors are
sophisticated enough that that the
clocks are synchronized they've got like
GPS yeah they're you know they're
they're resource-constrained but not
that bad so so so the clock synchronous
it's not I mean it's a good math
question but I'm not sure it's a
practical practical issue for them yeah
I don't know I mean it you know you
seems like so so so right now that right
now the model that everybody is
synchronized and the experiments that we
did everybody was synchronized and
everybody got hit with the same jail
matrix you know
sure ah so there could be no no no no
because there could be some initial
condition that has that has set them
vibrating so imagine you've got a string
and you and your initial condition is to
raise the string up like this and you
let it go there's yes yes yes so it's a
difference between initial condition and
no no it's not a stupid question that's
right yeah yeah
no no this is this is this is you know
purely nice nice master I should say not
yet no